R
JOINING ME TONIGHT.
GREAT STUFF, I APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tammy: EXPERTS ARE NOW
CLAIMINGS THAT MORE THAN
$400 BILLION IN PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT AID HAS BEEN STOLEN
WITH MUCH OF IT ENDING UP IN THE
HANDS OF, SURPRISE, FOREIGN
CRIME AS I UNDERSTAND CATS.
JOINING ME NOW REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN FROM UTAH BURGESS
OWENS A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
EDUCATION AND LABOR COMMITTEE
AND OBVIOUSLY A MAN WHO GOT
ELECTED BECAUSE WE WANT PEOPLE
IN WASHINGTON WHO CARE ABOUT
STUFF LIKE THIS.
SIR, WE LISTENED TO THIS.
GOVERNMENT WANTS TO TAKE MORE
CONTROL OVER OUR LIVES.
WE ARE TRYING TO GETTING MONEY
IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE.
IT'S THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT.
THE BEST MOST IMPORTANT COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD.
AND SOMEHOW $400 BILLION ENDS UP
WITH CRIMINALS SYNDICATES IN THE
HANDS OF, YOU KNOW, THE WORST OF
OUR ENEMIES.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THIS AS A
CONGRESSMAN, THAT THIS IS ABLE
TO HAPPEN IN THE 21st CENTURY?
WHAT DO YOU TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> WELL, LET ME JUST SAY THIS
FIRST, TAMMY.
I WAS TEMPTED TO STAND UP AND
GIVING STANDING OVATION FOR THAT
MONOLOGUE BUT I CONTROLLED
MYSELF.
NO, I TELL YOU VERY SIMPLY THIS
THIS IS EXAMPLE OF WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE LET ELITIST TAKE CHARGE.
IT'S THE SAME GROUP PAYING
PEOPLE TO STAY HOME, HAVE SMALL
BUSINESS